the g pro and now the super light is the
undisputed most popular high-end gaming
mouse but what if you don't like the
g-pro or maybe you're a bit of a hipster
well here's five alternatives to
consider the razer viper ultimate is the
gpro's biggest competitor it shares a
similar price tag at 150 us dollars but
if you're a claw user this might be a
better option for you next we have the
g303 now you can't get the original one
at the moment but trouty's got you his
upgraded version actually features the
same hardware as the super light mouth
easy a cheaper option is the extra fi m4
or m4 wireless they come in at 60
dollars and 100 us respectively and
plenty of pros have made the switch to
them over the last couple years the
glorious model 0 is another solid cheap
option it's 50 and only weighs 67 grams
lastly we can't make a mouse list
without zoey their ec series products
are still among the most popular
worldwide and for good reason